my mom she's amazing she's a very um
emotionally strong woman we couldn't
have been worse behaved children it was
four of us and we were all just like
fighting all the time and she was
working and like it would just would
have been like I truly don't know how
she did it I tell my mom that I'd paid
her mortgage yeah that was something
like when I first started working and I
started making money I was like speaking
with a business manager and they said
what do you want to do with your money
blah blah and I was like first thing I
want to pay off my mom's mortgage and I
said okay well it's going to be a long
time before you can afford to do that so
every couple months you check in I'll be
like do we have enough yet and he's like
no not yet we have enough yet no not yet
and then eventually he was like you
could afford to pay Mom's mortgage did
all the paperwork and stuff yeah it was
definitely one of the best moments of my
life